[Music]
so it seems like DC is really trying to
make a comeback here which is great it's
what we all want
I feel like Justice League was just a
super bummer especially right after
Wonder Woman had such great success and
was received so well by the fans
so with Justice League flopping so badly
the next movies that they put out are
going to have to be spectacular for the
most part and it seems like they're on
the right track with the upcoming movie
Green Lantern Corps there have been new
developments in the writing and our main
characters have been officially
confirmed but before we get started if
you would like to stay up to date with
DC and Marvel news hit that subscribe
button so our official characters for
Green Lantern Corps are Hal Jordan and
Jon Stewart this is definitely a step in
the right direction for DC Hal Jordan is
probably the best ring slinger out there
he's definitely the most famous and he's
probably the most loved and Jon Stewart
I think is right there with him I
personally love Jon Stewart and I think
a lot of the fans do as well really he's
an amazing Green Lantern and I was so
excited when I found out that it's
official that he's going to be one of
the two main characters there were
rumors going around that they were going
to choose new work Eric ters like Simon
Baz and Jessica Cruz but I think this is
a much better choice I think how and
John are just I think they're the two
most beloved Green Lantern's and let's
be honest Ryan Reynolds I love you and
it wasn't your fault but the first Green
Lantern in the DC EU
it sucked is a list Green Lantern RIPD
called selfless terrible blade Trinity
and this is a great chance for
redemption and with Jeff John stepping
down as DC entertainments president and
chief creative officer and becoming
involved in the writing and producing I
think that this is going to be a major
move in helping this particular film and
the other films that are about to come
be just amazing John launched his own
production company and on the website
you can see all the films that he's
going to have direct involvement with
and DC needs it they've really struggled
to compete with Marvel John's himself
did great work with the Green Lantern in
the comics so he is the perfect person
for this movie and I'm just really
excited about it so we have Hal Jordan
and Jon Stewart Hal Jordan who was an
Air Force pilot before he took on the
mantle of green lantern and Jon Stewart
who was a soldier in the Marines before
he took on the mantle Hal and Jon are
really a perfect pairing for this film
how is really just precision and power
he's pure power he's a master at
harnessing willpower a great example is
he destroyed Sinestro and an entire
planet with just pure brute force and
John is patient and restrained he's
calculating he saves his power for the
most important moments he constructed an
entire military to help him destroy an
army of black Lantern's so they're both
super strong but they have individual
skills that really complement each other
John is the man with a plan and if Hal
can follow his plan and unleash his
power as a part of John's plan then
they're practically unstoppable so I
think it's going to be an amazing movie
when it comes out and I think Jeff Jones
is going to do just a fantastic job on
it this movie and the other movies that
geoff johns is involved in that are
coming out before Green Lantern Corps I
think they're going to be really a step
above what the DC EU has given us lately
with the exception of Wonder Woman of
course so that is it for the Green
Lantern Corps update let me know how you
feel about Jon Stewart joining the DC EU
and what are you most excited to see
when Hal and John work together if you
enjoyed this video give it a thumbs up
please and be sure to subscribe to my
channel to stay up to date and all
things DC Marvel and superhero thank you
so much for watching
woof woof
you
[Music]